[Music]  that's Prince Harry playing a game of  handball with a group of adorable kids  in London on Friday the 32 year old  royal hit the field at Street games spit  and fat even and we can't get over the  pics of him unleashing his inner child  I'm going kid inside of me I wanted to  keep dogs ID or kids check out Harry  looking dapper in a navy dress shirt and  slacks very well dressed to play soccer  tennis and cricket with the children the  Red Hat royal was spotted staying on the  sidelines for most of the games at one  point he appeared to get a bit  competitive picking up a little boy with  possession of the ball but it doesn't  give much cuter than this Harry all  smiles while passing out lunches over at  the food station following a fun-filled  day on the field